this year I was in one of the hottest
movies of the year strata Compton it was
the number one movie for three weeks in
a row
I played one Angie I had a nice little
cameo in the film and I booked that last
year 2014 and I haven't booked anything
since I've been going out on different
editions my managers been sending me out
my agents been sending me out and all of
a sudden four days ago I get a call
saying can you be on set for a pilot so
I just don't think I'm the audition type
of guy you know I think I should just
get those calls every now and then like
hey be on set and make it happen because
yeah I think I'm like a red and black
flannel or is it rather like you were in
a recording studio
yeah studio but I was wearing like a
blue I was wearing a black shirt with a
blue top over it okay yeah I remember
them referencing you and I remember
seeing you in it yeah so you auditioned
for that and then how long before you
heard that was crazy story - so audition
I got the audition then I got the
callback like four weeks ago didn't I
didn't hear anything at all four strata
content so next thing you know I find
out this shooting and my girlfriend
she's also an actress she went on the
set for just an extra she didn't even
notice Australia competition she got
there she was like oh my gosh try to cop
in the shooting and I was just thinking
like oh man I didn't get the damn rope
but then I'm like how long you gonna be
on set she's like two days I got to
sneak on with you the next day so that
Friday next day I snuck on set with her
I hopped in the van with the original
members played it off like I was
somebody and next thing I was on set and
I rent it to my first ever acting coach
Dustin Felder and he was like man you
look good I was like yeah I did for
Angie have they cast him and he was like
nah not at all I'm just like man I was
like not gonna play the road he's like
man you look good so that night he told
my girl that I was probably gonna have
the role
yeah then the next day I got a call from
my manager is saying shoving you booked
the role I had to be able to set the
next day at 4:45 in the morning so these
things just keep happening to me you
know but you grew up in LA right you
didn't come here from another state boy
I raised
interesting so is one of your parents in
the business is that how you know my
little brother he's in the business he
was a child actor now he's turning like
socialite yeah I don't know if you guys
Temari Maurice hangs out with every
celebrity out there pretty much yeah
okay so and he's your your older brother
my little brother a little bit so you
saw his career and you've always been
interested in acting and did you take
classes you said Judge coach yes yes I
took classes with Bobby chance in choice
Skinner which our choice gonna work
under Bobby chance so it's all the same
type of structure and stuff like that
but my little brother he was an actor
and I would take him with different sets
and one day I was on the set of Ugly
Betty
you guys remember showing Betty Vanessa
Williams she's like you have such a
great look and such a great presence you
start acting and from there I was like I
gotta start acting so first thing I did
look for acting coach and made it happen
in the first acting coach that I found
was Dustin Felder which was eventually
the acting coach for strata Compton so
that was six years so how everything
works that's a six year process
you